Speaker 1: OK, I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this next story. It's just downright bizarre.
Maggie Haberman from The New York Times published
a note that was sent to Mar a Lago club members
last week. Mar a Lago is Donald Trump's one of
Donald Trump's clubs, and I guess it's where
Donald Trump currently lives down in Florida.
Trump sent a note out saying that he was going to
be deejaying this weekend, and this is this is a
former president. It's a very, very strange thing
Trump would be. Trump is going to be deejaying.
I don't know what else to say. This note was sent
out on Wednesday. Great music will be played
during dinner on Friday and Saturday evenings,
with President Trump playing the role of
disc jockey. The music will be amazing. It
will be lots of fun and we will go until the late
evening for those who will be unable to be seated.
The bar will be open for drinks. We look
forward to seeing everyone again very soon.
President Donald Trump like it is.
Speaker 3: Is this sad
Speaker 1: in some way? Obviously, it's listen,
there's nothing wrong with a president, Jiang
in principle. But is there something sad about
what Trump is now relegated to? We saw that video
of him entering the Mar a Lago brunch room and
asking for applause, and there was sort of like a
little bit of applause. Now he's deejaying at Mar
a Lago. It seems it reeks of desperation to just
hold any attention from people that you can. And
also, I mean, in the same way that Trump doesn't
really have friends in the way you and I probably
think about what it means to have friends,
Trump doesn't really understand or follow popular
culture, so it's also kind of hard to imagine.
Trump picking songs, I mean, it's just
it's all downright bizarre. But it is
the last attempt to remain
relevant during this period between
losing the 2020 election and getting involved
in 2022 and maybe running again in 2024. But I
guess one of the fringe benefits of a membership
to Mar a Lago that Trump is now the House DJ on
Friday and Saturday nights. Good work.
If you can get it, I guess I would say